Welcome to English in a Minute.
If you have ever heard American English before, you had probably heard this phrase:...
..."That's just my two cents."
Does it make you wonder what pennies have to do with giving someone advice?
Let's listen and find out.
I love Nickelback.
I think their music is really boring and everybody doesn't like them,...
...but that's just my two cents.
"My two cents" is a different way of saying "my opinion" or "my thoughts on the subject."
Two cents isn't a lot of money.
So saying something is "just my two cents worth,"...
...is saying that your opinion might not be worth that much to someone else...
In life, everyone will not always agree with you.
So saying this lets people know that.
And that's English in a Minute.